good evening everyone I'm Carla Cohen
I'm one of the owners of politics and
prose and I want to welcome you here
tonight and I want to welcome our
viewers on c-span and remind them that
we in Washington have no vote in
Congress and I want them to make it
known to their congressmen that they
care about our having a say as well as
they they're having a say I'm very
honored to have zip new Brzezinski here
tonight I of course had to google him a
little bit to find out his how far back
his his his his he went in our in
American history and he hit he has
reached through the whole second half of
the 20th century and had such a large
impact and I think that he if we could
say his name more easily his name would
truly be a household room it is a
household name it's this is a terrific
book for those of us who are yearning to
have a coherent foreign policy I think
you could do no better than to turn to
the preface and in which mr. Brzezinski
outlines a whole set of issues that the
United States has to deal with in fact I
was thinking maybe I should copy this
and send it to Senator Kerry what are
the I guess you speak to him yourself
though what are the main threats to
America given its hegemonic hegemony
status is America entitled to more
security than other nations how should
America cope with potentially lethal
threats that increasingly emanate not
from powerful rivals but from weak foes
can America constructively manage its
long-term relationship with the Islamic
world many of whose 1.2 billion people
in
leave you America as implacably hostile
can America act decisively to resolve
the israeli-palestinian conflict given
the overlapping but legitimate claims of
two peoples to the same land what is
needed to creates political stability in
the volatile new global Balkans located
within the southern rim of Central Asia
can America Ford to genuine partnership
with Europe given Europe slow progress
to political unity but increasing
economic might can Russia no longer
arrival to America be drawn into an
american-led Atlantic framework and
their other points as well which are
discussed in this marvelous book the
choice thank you very much for coming
tonight we're really happy to have you
with us thank you very much miss Goren
ladies and gentlemen first of all it's
going said that if my name was easier to
pronounce it would be a household name
and that made me think of an article
that was written some years ago quite a
few years ago about me in Newsweek
magazine in the article ended by saying
America is he on the country in which
someone called being a Brzezinski can
make a name for himself without changing
it and actually not only do I remember
that quote but your reference evokes
another memory which was when I begun to
note a little bit selfishly and
immodestly when I was still quite a
young man that I was beginning to be
kind of viewed more and more in the
American political in elite I suppose
that maybe I should change my name was
simplified
and I was then still an assistant
professor at Harvard and I said to
myself hell no in if America is what I
think America is I shouldn't have to do
that and that's another aspect without
anecdote I'm sorry to be late and but I
was on the Jim Lehrer show trying to
explain that words have meaning and that
it's important that it's important to
use words in a credible fashion and that
was apropos our policy in Iraq and the
presidential statement on that subject
yesterday and one of the points I made
was that credibility depends on veracity
and precision anyone is emphasized
careless or deliberately misleading one
loses something very precious and that
was the case with the justification of
the war in Iraq on the grounds that it
possessed weapons of mass destruction in
listening to the president respectfully
yesterday I was struck by the fact that
he never once mentioned weapons of mass
destruction the war in Iraq now we were
told is the central front in the war on
terrorism not much evidence was provided
for that proposition and perhaps that is
just as well because to the extent that
it becomes a major front in the war on
terrorism it may not be unconnected to
the fact that we went into Iraq and the
other point I made on television was the
president repeatedly said yesterday that
will be granting and I'm now quoting for
sovereignty to the Iraqi government
while there will be an American
proconsul in a fortress in the middle of
the country's capital while there will
be 140,000 American
troops in the country subject to
American command and staying there it
wasn't clear how long but the
presumption was until democracy
flourishes in Iraq there is some problem
with the precision involving a statement
and that is not unrelated to the larger
dilemmas that America confronts in the
world today and this is what my book is
about namely that leadership in the
world of the world's paramount power an
American paramountcy is indeed
unprecedented still doesn't mean that
America has to ignore the need for
friends and does not need to base its
leadership on some degree of
international consensus I argue in my
book that American power is indeed
paramount but that doesn't make America
omnipotent and therefore one has to be
again very precise in defining where
America needs to use its power even
unilaterally which under some
circumstances may be necessary and
particularly in the face of genuinely
imminent threats and where it is wider
wiser and more beneficial in the long
run to work with others even if it
involves some degree of accommodation of
one's own definition of one's own most
immediate interests I believe these
distinctions have not been made lately
and I do think that there hasn't been a
serious national debate about about
America's role in the world in the last
several years now there is a reason for
that and the reason does provide some
degree I suppose of excuse 911 911 was a
tremendous shock it absolutely shocked
America
it didn't change the world but it
changed America and because we are so
powerful it then in turn changed the
world because that changed us and it
also stifled domestically in a serious
national debate about foreign policy I
was really visually struck by that when
almost two years ago a year and a half
ago the president in the Rose Garden was
in effect laying out the case for
unilaterally going to war in Iraq and
among the cheerleaders in the Rose
Garden were two very prominent Democrats
who subsequently were running for
president not going to mention their
names but you probably all know who they
were and that was part and parcel of
this the munition of national debate of
searching for a meaningful definition of
American role in the world when
America's on the one hand paramount on
the other hand vulnerable we haven't had
such debate and my book was written in
part to provide that debate and I was
quite struck that particular one
interview him in one major review of the
book the review in The New York Times
and the reviewers said there hasn't been
a response to bush's new strategic
doctrine which is the product of new
global circumstances from the other side
until the appearance of this book and
that this book now provides the basis
for a serious debate which doesn't
reject the novelty of the challenges
that we face and the need for addressing
them responsibly but which argues that
is somewhat a different set of
priorities and emphasis is needed if
there is to be a meaningful response I
don't claim the book is infallible I
don't claim that necessarily provides
all the right answers there are many
things in the book which could be
improved on
conscious of that but I hope it leads to
more serious debate in part because I
think we badly needed and in part
because i believe the balance in our
national definition of our global
priorities has been spewed quite badly
lately and i'll end on that and my point
here is this we have been involved in
the world since on a massive scale since
world war two and very much as a leading
power since world war two although our
power has risen we have had on the whole
a fairly successful foreign policy and
the principal rival to us given us 45
years a totalitarian soviet union is no
longer around in some significant
measure because of our policies and our
policies were sustained throughout this
entire period of time by in a formal
sense some significant degree of
bipartisanship but within that basically
by a sense of prevailing and continuing
moderation for the last three years for
the first time we have had a foreign
policy which is extremist in its outlook
and therefore potentially reckless in
its consequences extremist therefore
reckless and that is significant that is
important but the extremism of the right
should not be answered by extremism of
the left because neither extremism is
going to work and the country has been
wise in those 45 years several times in
rejecting leadership that offered itself
on the basis of extremism you might
remember the phrase extremism in the
defense of Liberty is no vice that was
one form of extremism there was another
extremism lesson 10 years later which
called a ball about on America to come
home meaning
what about the rest of the world that we
get the damn about it the point is the
country has been wise in avoiding
extremism I think it's important to
return it to it we cannot return to it
simply by conducting a national debate
in which the extremism of the right is
challenged by extremism of the left we
need a serious debate over central
issues I hope the choice will help to
shape the debate and ultimately to make
the right choice thank you questions at
the mic good mic right in the middle
over here you have to go around that's
right you're in the right place is it
yeah oh I just want to say I'm very
impressed by your book are very
refreshing that there used to be some
national security advisors that work
conceptual thinkers rather than
cheerleaders and in that connection I
also admired your lack of rigidity in
recognizing the fact that things are
moving so fast both technologically and
and socially that almost all
prescriptions have to be tentative and
reserved now there's one statement you
made that I would like clarification on
you talked about how the hegemony of
America and probably any other
individual power the this era is over
and we have to turn more to
international consensus and cooperation
and you talk about supranational
Arrangements being
as something that we have to look to now
of course that term is used in so many
senses that like clarification how you
mean it some people are equated with
world government okay people like stroke
tall but Walter Cronkite and even Albert
Einstein and make no apologies for it to
other people is to fill in this thing
I'd like you to define your sense there
are you post a supranational thank you
thank you very much I do say explicitly
in the book I think world government is
a premature concept at this stage
someday probably there will be some form
of world government because someday the
owner alternative to it will be massive
global chaos we are becoming more
interwoven more interdependent more
interactive more contiguous to each
other because distance is shrinking so
we are moving towards more and more
supranational arrangements but I think
what one has to recognize that this is a
progression and not a leave at this
stage even if somehow or other one were
to leap into world government one would
probably soon find that one could not
enforce it that they're just wouldn't be
enough power at the center to create a
world government and imposes uniformity
in every respect on the entire world and
even as powerful country as the United
States could not do it so the
progression has to be by stages at the
same time the reality is that we're all
moving collectively towards more and
more supranational authority we don't
want to accept this stage the kyoto
protocol's or the International Court of
Criminal Justice or we don't want to
accept other limitations on our
sovereignty but at the same time we are
accepting some limitations for example
the World Trade Organization is a very
important international organization
whose rules we have to accept now we
often violate those rules because we're
the strongest economy but when another
a strong economy like the European Union
challenges us we begin to respect the
rules of the game so we are moving that
way too and even what's happening last
two days in Iraq is a kind of belated
bow towards super nationality we started
off by rejecting any role for the UN and
but now for example in order to
legitimate our presence we are beginning
to accept the fact that it will be a UN
official who will be choosing the Iraqi
government that's going to be serving
not in full sovereignty but with limited
sovereignty while we were still there
that is again a progression so I think
one has to think of it in those terms
yes ma'am yes first thank you for
everything you continue to do your wise
and brilliant words your book jacket
says you identify America's crucial
strategic imperative as promoter of the
global common good what advice do you
have for president carry in January
well I think I can answer very briefly
if he's going to be well prepared he has
a certain book to read that's pie that's
250 pages long uh I I never disagree
with what you say i have a problem
however with the unspoken a material
that r is going on um if we look at
halliburton and their books out now in
haliburton and the influence of the
corporation behind the government scenes
this is one of our most difficult
problems to deal with if we only deal
with it at the surface level such as
you're speaking now and they're very
important words so don't get me wrong on
that but if we never know who's pulling
the strings behind the scenes for
example the nation state and I addressed
you once on this before the nation
states have become significantly weaker
now but what has happened is they've
been replaced by this corporate overlay
the people we don't hear about the
corporations that have influence on
different national governments
throughout the world and i'm not against
globalization i'm not against free trade
and things of that nature but what i am
against is the fact that the corporate
influences are so great in comparison to
the people's the so-called democracies
that we need to get a grip on them and
for example when you spoke at two
Democrats I appreciate your saying that
but it's your reluctance to name names
and tell us what's really going on that
is really the problem well thank you
very much I can tell that you believe
and stripping down to the essentials
but and and I can believe in you
dressing up to cover up yeah very good
very good yeah
that makes us even I think you know the
nature of democracy is by definition a
very complex process and anybody who
wants to have a perfect democracy
essentially is dreaming about a utopia I
mean the human condition by definition
involves some imperfections some
limitations there are obvious
disparities in influence and power
between certain organized interests
financial resources and individuals it's
no doubt about it now the vote is still
an individual vote and while maybe the
choice of candidates is unevenly
influenced the ultimate vote is still
one in which everybody's equal but to
make a democracy more operative we do
have opportunities for social
organizations non-government
organizations trade unions policy groups
and so forth which to some extent and
galvanize opposition can galvanize
commitment to certain causes an act to
create some sort of rough balance in
this otherwise very complicated and
frequently an even game that the
democracy entails but I know of no
systemic concept that is practical in
implementation of social political
organization which would create perfect
balance between not on individuals but
the entities groups organizations with
which individuals associated selves and
I think blueprints for such a utopia
don't really exist in a credible sense
and to the extent that they exist they
tend to be sort of crackpot ish or like
Marxism which believes in creating a
classless society produce so to speak
classless oppression by a new
bureaucracy which allegedly embodied the
concept of the classless society but
imposing society
massive controls which perhaps equalize
suffering but that's not a major
accomplishment well that's a nice answer
but it wasn't to the question i guess
but that's all right well i did my best
i'm sorry i don't satisfy you want to
ask you about Israel and Palestine where
you have been consistently a clear
speaker about the importance of settling
that a issue a few months ago you were
among many former officials who spoke
out and signed statements in support of
the Geneva initiative which I applaud
and the aisle on Serena so baya effort
at stimulating both joint Israeli and
Palestinian efforts to have a statement
of principles that would resolve the
issue it's a very constructive effort in
the Geneva initiative and in the aisle
on no sabe a statement I happen to have
spent some time recently in both Israel
and in the wetland on the west bank and
Palestine working with groups that were
designed to strengthen and and really
capture the vibrancy of civil society in
Palestine I was also there when
President Bush and Prime Minister Sharon
had their joint statement so my question
to you is what are the elements that you
would say are necessary for Senator
Kerry to be willing to state so that he
is in a position to govern in the event
that he is elected senator Kerry
disappointingly just and I'm an
enthusiastic supporter of Senator Kerry
ah but he and he just rolled over at the
time of the sure own Bush effort and I'm
speaking as an American Jew who
seriously Jewish and there are many
different points of view in the Jewish
community that want to help create space
for American political leaders to be
able to carry through the principal you
earlier talked about about accommodating
different interests while protecting
one's interest of creating and
protecting a free and safe Israel so I'd
like to I'd like you to go even deeper
than you have in your book thank you let
me make two preliminary comments perhaps
of a somewhat personal nature first of
all for a variety of personal reasons I
am engaged in that issue and I do take
some flak because of that engagement I'm
also involved in some organizations
which are active in the area such as
seeds for peace which is an
israeli-palestinian effort to promote
relations among young people an
israeli-palestinian orphanage the Rabine
Institute in Jerusalem and so forth so
I'm involved also so to speak more on
the ground and on just on the level of
high policy secondly I don't speak for
the correct administration and I'm no
spokesman for Senator Kerry now to the
substance I think that what is needed
and that pertains to your question
regarding what position senator Kerry
could take is a clarification of the
American position regarding the eventual
shape of a peace settlement I am
conscious of the fact that the word
imposed peace is anathema to a good part
of the Jewish community and I can
understand why that is so but that is
not an argument in my judgment against
the US clarifying publicly what much of
the international community accepts as
roughly an equitable formula for an
eventual solution and which individually
initiated israeli-palestinian dialogues
have generated and you have referred to
one very important development along
those lines named with the geneva
accords which represent a virtual
agreement between
in Palestine about 50 pages of text with
great many maps addressing all of the
key issues those of you who are
interested and that subject should read
the document because it shows one that
it is possible to reach a compromise
formula at least among well-meaning
Israelis and Palestinians secondly it is
possible also to negotiate the details
of that agreement because it doesn't
merely state some generalities it
actually goes into the nuts and bolts of
the specifics of the general formulas
including detailed maps my view is at
this stage the United States cannot come
out with anything as precise and
definite as the Geneva Accords because
there may be specifics that can be
negotiated in other ways but it is I
think appropriate for the United States
to join the rest of the international
community and those Israelis and
Palestinians who are dedicated to a
peaceful solution in staking that there
are certain fundamental principles on
which a peace settlement ought to be
based and these could be the following
one there cannot be as a practical
matter a right of return except maybe in
some symbolic exceptions you know for 80
year old Palestinian grandmother's who
are not going to give birth to any more
Palestinians but can then rejoin their
families in Israel if they indeed exist
secondly no automatic return to the 67
lines because some facts on the ground
cannot be reversed for example the
heavily urbanized Israeli settlements
immediately around Jerusalem and
immediately contiguous to the 67 lines
they have to be in effect absorbed into
Israel third there has to be territorial
compensation however for that because as
it is five and a half to six million
israelis and roughly five million
Palestinians are currently sharing the
same land but Israel already has
seventy-eight percent of that
land and the Arabs or Palestinians on
the 22 if there were any further changes
shrinking the small but a single segment
it will simply make the acceptance of
peace impossible just not look
legitimate so some equitable equitable
exchange of land here would be required
next item I believe that's the fourth is
that inland settlements have to be
vacated and they can be used to then
settle quite a few of the Palestinian
refugees who would not be allowed into
Israel but could be allowed into the
Palestinian state the next and fifth is
retention of united Jerusalem as a city
but two capitals in it and again the
Geneva Accords provide for that and the
last one is some form of international
or NATO presence in the Palestinian
state to ensure its demilitarization and
as a further reinforcements for peace
solution I think in the United States
took the position publicly it would
greatly strengthen those in Israel and
those in Palestine who's seen the
present road map essentially roadmap to
an unclear destination with each fearing
the other and each anxious to trip up
the other on that road to an unknown
destination which each fears will be to
the disadvantage of itself that will
clarify that and that would help I
happen to think that a presidential
candidate at this stage of history would
in fact gain support in America from
saying something like that from not
endorsing in the bush our own formula
which is very one-sided and I think
compounds is suffering of those involved
I think the majority of the American
Jewish community realizes that piece
isn't the long-term interest of Israel
and of the united states that if we are
driven out of the Middle East one would
not see a safe Israel for very long time
to come and therefore I think of
forthright statement to that effect
would not be politically costly which is
of course whatever political candidate
is concerned about would not be
politically costly in fact I think
probably would win votes and that
competition and pandering is never
successful in the long run because
doesn't define leadership so this is why
I feel but I'm not a professional
politician and there are obviously
voices the country who think that
perhaps you may be wiser to defer a
serious discussion of this issue an
obviously president bush either
sincerely or simply expediently
calculates that you know in embracing
sharon is the man of peace is some or
other politically beneficial that's why
i frame the question in terms of being
able to govern if elected well for that
reason yeah but the other name the
element of some optimism here is that
events i think are dictating a certain
clarity i think more and more people
realize now that a status quo based
merely on force will not work in iraq
and will not work in the
israeli-palestinian conflict and that
the two issues are connected one of the
things that I argue is we can't get out
of Iraq without making progress and
Israeli Palestinian issue because if we
don't then we will have an Iraq in spite
of our military victory that is
anti-american and anti-israeli the same
time well I hope you use the magic of
the op-ed to put into words your would
you just said and you're working through
the settlement allow Israel and
Palestine read the next issue of New
Republic
dr. Burzynski thanks for this book and
for your other books I also were struck
by the lack of debate you mentioned that
there was no real debate in the prelude
to the war in Iraq from the left I was
amazed that there was not more voice
yours accepted from those who are sort
of traditional as opposed to
neoconservatives I have here in mind for
example Henry Kissinger I was hoping
that he would bring back some of the
statements that he wrote very early on
for example in a world restored he said
in a world of in a global situation of
sovereign states absolute security for
anyone can only be bought at the price
of absolute insecurity for all the rest
and it seems to me that we're seeing the
consequences of going after absolute
security secondly another time he's
distinguished the idealistic
revolutionary ruler from The Statesman
and he said the revolutionary idealist
justifies his actions on the basis of
the incandescent of his vision about
what will come about if all goes well
the statesman knows that he's
responsible for all that goes wrong as
well and finally another one that I was
haunted by at the time that we were
dismissing Europe he said Europe
Americans think that history holds out
possibilities for ultimate human
improvement and Europeans know that
history is ultimate know in their bones
that history is ultimately tragic if
that kind of voice had been mobilized
maybe some people would have taken the
second look I wonder what your take on
that is well first of all I'm very
impressed by your memory it is secondly
I think these are very eloquent
statements and i'll try to remember them
so that the next time i discuss or
debate in with Henry I will use them
usually you wonder who's Kissinger now
but you know it's like I can't I can't
really speak for him he clearly has
thought through and has considered
seriously the kind of concerns that I
have expressed and he hasn't shared them
and that's his privilege he is of course
also probably closer to the
administration than I am so that also is
a factor and perfectly understandable
factor so I can't explain his position I
respect his position I also say this in
all fairness that we have been pitted by
the mass media as kind of rivals and
people like the fact that on Iraq we
disagree and we disagreed already year
full year ago on the subject of weapons
of mass destruction but outside of that
I have to say in all frankness and
fairness that the most issues we tend to
agree in so that I don't want to take
advantage of the fact that I have the
floor here and its seemingly somewhat
sympathetic audience to slamming dr.
Burzynski thanks for your book it's
refreshing to read it as a matter of
free will not required reading um my
question is having been in this town for
ten years and worked on the hill I I'm
alarmed by the dearth of foreign policy
experience and serious focus in the
Democratic Party my question you is
simple what can the Democratic Party do
that's my party to institutionally to to
meet this debate in the middle on terms
that are that don't represent the shrill
leftism that you say cannot be the terms
that have to meet the shrill right ism
well there are a number of Democrats who
are discussing these issues and
increasingly so as the problematics of
Iraq become more apparent there is a new
center for Democratic policy making and
thinking run by Podesta which is playing
I think an increasingly important role I
think the presidential campaign by
necessity creates a dynamic
a pressure for sharper clearer
definition of a comprehensive democratic
alternative so I see some of that
underway whether it will emerge with
sufficient clarity and whether some of
the issues may not be stated more
sharply is an open question I don't know
I hope that that would be the case but I
see some movement in that direction
Brezinski you seem to have more faith in
Palestinian moderates and Arabs
moderates generally than I see grounds
for my question is why isn't there
something like an insistence on all Arab
states as a sign of goodwill and as a
statement against the suicide bombers
and the radicals opening full diplomatic
relations with Israel and also Israel
having full membership and all UN
organizations I believe there's still
excluded from the Red Cross why put or
talk about putting more pressure on
Israel instead of doing that first well
first of all I don't think advocates of
a peace settlement under the compromise
formula is putting pressure in Israel it
is an arguing for a solution to conflict
that has lasted for 50 years and which
is debilitating for both parties and for
the region so first of all let's get rid
of the idea that talking about peace is
pressure in Israel because that very
idea says something and I didn't mean to
say that okay good enough and secondly
on the question of recognition of Israel
I think in the Beirut declaration more
than a year ago the Arabs actually
committed themselves to doing that as
part of a peace settlement and I would
expect that that would be a scenic one
on one of the absolutely essential
conditions of a peace settlement it's
hard to imagine them doing that ahead of
a settlement why well all you have to
ask yourself what is happening on Gaza
what is happening on in West Bank if
they accept now to have diplomatic
relations with Israel there in a way
condoning that so you can't ask them to
do that in in the absence of a peace
settlement but are we condoning the sous
Obama's by not since the Palestinians
can't seem to produce any authority to
establish domestic policy in their own
land that I think involves also a closer
look at the problem the Palestinians
don't have a state of their own they
have a Palestinian Authority has been
pulverized in the course of the last two
years totally pulverized its police
force was smashed its leaders were
arrested in this setting suicide bombing
becomes a kind of a brutal irrational
ugly reaction that's almost inevitable
in that situation I thought the suicide
bombings proceeded no I'm right not if
you look if you know I don't really want
to debate in detail the history of the
palestinian-israeli conflict especially
with kind of finger-pointing you're more
responsible than I no no you are a more
responsible I but if you go back to the
rubinyan era until Robyn was
assassinated there was very little
violence and you have to ask yourself
why was Rabine assassinated what was the
atmosphere which could which prompted
his assassination who was labeling
Rabine publicly as a traitor as a
traitor to Israel and what has followed
since the death of Robin I think these
are relevant questions but I would also
argue they're not central in the sense
if one merely gets in the state of mind
of saying well there can be no peace
because you're more guilty than I then
you're going to have an endless debate
the question is how do you solve it how
you terminate it and the only way you
can terminate it is by defining formulas
with which both sides can live and then
work from that towards the elimination
of those forces that are in favor of
violence or off only a one-sided victory
that's on the way to overcome it unless
you expect a total victor of one side
over the other I mean there are Arabs
would like to drive Israel into the sea
that's a total solution they're Israelis
who would like to have a greater Israel
and even expel all Palestinians from the
West Bank that's also a total solution I
don't think either one
is workable so we have to find something
in between thank you for your response
kidding me dr. Brzezinski I want to ask
you about the issue that's very often
overlooked in the united states but i
hope that because of your background
okay it's perfect two more oh yes
perfect good but i hope that because of
your back under the european affairs you
can give me a better grasp on it as we
know in the last few decades a huge
number of Muslims aren't doing Europe I
mean in 2020 twenty percent of French
population is going to be Muslim and the
most are the most popular name for a new
born male in the Amsterdam is Mohammed I
want to ask you two questions first to
what point how greatly will this
influence the transatlantic relationship
between us and europe this changes in
geo political and social political
structure of europe and second how will
the transfer to a new european countries
a new countries in european union will
we see a jihad being taught on the
streets of Warsaw it always been
imposing I but well you know it really
depends on the evolution of the
relationship between the west and Islam
if one believes that the clash of
civilizations primarily clash between
the west and Islam is inevitable then I
think the answer to your question
becomes very obvious if one things that
can be avoided then I think we're going
to have a much more mixed situation we
in this country believe in diversity and
a very flexible definition of
assimilation and by and large it has
worked it has worked for many many
decades in this country we excluded
blacks from participation because that
is a very visible distinction and yet we
have learned to overcome that we are
beginning to assimilate much and much
larger groups of asians in our society
even though for much of our history
essentially european-based we are doing
the same with Hispanics the Muslim
population in this country is also
growing it's also rose up to the
Europeans to find a formula for
coexistence otherwise done alternative
is a bar to immigration that's a little
difficult to sustain in a continent in
which the population is becoming very
old if the Europeans bar immigrants
who's going to be doing the heavy
lifting in and the populations would be
drastically declining so they have to be
open to immigration and if they're going
to be open to immigration they have to
facilitate a simulation and cooperation
and diversity and one will never do that
the one starts with the premise that
anyone who has named mohammed is
automatically an enemy and a propagator
of jihad but how do you assimilate them
if most of the Muslims who are wood
coming to Europe para have a very
extreme region believes and they are
very often running away from their
countries because their countries are
not extreme enough well if you are
factually correct that would be a
problem the problem is you're not and
I'll just give you one example we'll
stop at that there are several million
Muslims in Germany and just think who
they are they're Turks their
assimilating quite well and so forth in
France the picture is more complicated
but quite a few Algerians Moroccans are
doing extremely well in becoming so to
speak part of the French community the
picture is much more mixed then I think
you appreciate ok thank you thank you
dr. Brzezinski I have a quick question I
was wondering if if you could answer I'm
an international students here and I
study international affairs and for all
the four years that I have been here
I've seen that for me America and a lot
of my friends that I know back in Europe
it sort of stopped stopped having this
ideological appeal that it has had as a
passion for freedom and American culture
and American values especially in light
of events in Iraq and I was just
wondering if you see it as a long-term
development and do you see it as a
threat to
maybe the position of America and the
world and also do you see it as
something that might threaten America's
appeal peace in the world well as you
can probably sense from some of the
discussion there is a potential in this
country for a view of society in a view
of the world that's congenial to the
notion of a fortress America exclusion
of others self-defense to the point of
supremacy of all those who have a
different point of view that kind of an
attitude can also be stimulated by fear
and anxiety and 911 has produced a lot
of fear and anxiety and we see it
reflected in some measure at least in
some portions of the Patriot Act which
should places in jeopardy not only the
rights of foreigners who may be in fact
conspiring against us but even the
rights of American citizens and that's a
very important change in the definition
of America so I guess my bottom line is
that a Democratic Society however
imperfect and I emphasize the
imperfection of democracy is a very
fragile thing and one has to be very
deliberate about protecting it and the
promotion of some degree of
international stability and peace is
also a very delicate process who doesn't
lend itself to concepts of total victory
of one side over the other nor except in
the most unusual of circumstances a
confrontation of total good versus total
evil